dans le contexte déjà tendu de la crise
sanitaire une perspective qui inquiète
les milieux économiques le retour de
l'inflation pour l'instant mesurer la
hausse des prix semble s'installer à la
faveur de la flambée des cours de
matières premières et alors que les
banques centrales continuent de faire
tourner leur planche à billets alors
dans quelle mesure cette relation
naissante est elle une menace pour notre
pouvoir d'achat
allons-nous connaître un emballement
comparable à celui des années 70 c'est
l'objet de l'édito échos ce soir bonsoir
jacques sapir
bonsoir ces feignasses aujac sommes nous
vraiment à la veille d'une forte poussée
d'inflation comme certains en tout cas
le craignent alors c'est tout à fait
normal que les gens craignent
l'inflation
parce que s'il y avait une inflation
maintenant alors que les revenus sont
absolument gelé ça pourrait avoir des
conséquences tout à fait grave
mais si on en croit les chiffres de
l'insee il n'y a pas de réel redémarrage
de l'inflation est en tous les cas il
n'y a pas de problème à court terme même
si il y a à l'évidence un problème lié
lui à la question des matières premières
et donc ça veut dire que sur la question
de l'inflation
et bien tout n'est pas aussi simple
qu'il y paraît alors chacun commençons
par le commencement si j'ose dire que
disent les chiffres de l'inflation
bon si on prend les chiffres de l'insee
on voit tout de suite que le taux
d'inflation en france n'a jamais été
aussi bas on était au début des années
1990 autour de 2 3%
on est tombé sauf un petit pic
d'inflation en 2018 on est tombé en
dessous de 1%
donc on voit bien là qu'il n'y a pas de
problème immédiat dans tous les cas y
envoyer qui a pas de tendance à la
remontée de l'inflation même si et ça
c'est un point qu'il faut qu'il faut
bien regarder il y a
depuis quelques mois une petite tendance
à la remontée de l'inflation
alors pourquoi cette crainte diffuse
alors il faut savoir que quand on parle
de l'inflation et quand l'insee parle de
l'inflation à l'analyse diverses choses
il ya évidemment l'indicé des prix à la
consommation c'est ce qu'on appelle gros
m globalement l'inflation et puis il ya
un autre indice qu'on appelle
l'inflation sous jacente ce sont les
prix des matières premières alors on le
voit aussi sur ce graphique il y à une
baisse globale de l' indice des prix à
la consommation et de l'inflation sous
jacente
sauf que depuis la fin du quatrième
trimestre et avec les premiers mois de
l'année et bien l'inflation sous-jacente
qui est cette courbe rouge qu'on voit à
côté des courbes bleus et des courbes
jaune
et bien cette courbe rouge elle est en
train de remonter et cette inflation
sous jacente
il faut le savoir c'est essentiellement
les matières premières et le pétrole
alors justement jacques à quoi est due
cette hausse des matières premières en
particulier comme vous le dites des
cours du pétrole
alors pour ce qui concerne le pétrole on
est dans une situation qui est quand
même très intéressante
rappelez vous il ya un an au mois de
mars 2020 on avait fait une émission où
on parlait des prix négatifs du pétrole
le pétrole était au plus bas
il a remonté c'est un parti normal mais
il a remonté très vite il a été en
moyenne autour de 54 dollars au mois de
janvier soit il sera probablement 60
dollars au mois de février et il ya des
analystes qui disent qu'ils pourraient
atteindre jusqu'à 75 dollars d'ici la
fin de l'année
qu'est ce qui se passe mais ils se
cassent deux choses d'une part on a des
pays qui ont redémarré 1
la chine a redémarré les pays qui sont
autour de la chine la corée taïwan
vietnam états ont redémarré donc qui dit
redémarrage économique dit besoin
d'énergie besoin de pétrole
d'un autre côté les pays producteurs eux
ont beaucoup baissé leur production à
cause de la crise qu'on a connus avant
même les effets de la crise sanitaire
cette crise du pétrole que l'on a connu
au mois de mars de l'année dernière et
ils ont maintenu d'une certaine manière
les contraintes sur la production alors
ajoutons à cela évidemment la vague de
froid qui a touché les états unis le
texas et le dakota qui sont deux zones
importantes de production et donc on a
aujourd'hui un déséquilibre important
entre eux
la demande pour le pétrole et la
production et c'est pour cela que les
prix sont en train d'augmenter
déjà que ce phénomène est ce qu'il est
limité au marché du pétrole
non justement et c'est quelque chose
d'assez important on voit que l'ensemble
des prix des matières premières est en
train d'augmenter alors on voit aussi
sur ce graphique que savaient chuté avec
la crise sanitaire mais que là ça
remonte et ça remonte de manière
particulièrement important qu'est ce que
ça veut dire
eh bien ça veut dire qu'il y à des
pénuries alors on sait qu'il ya des
pénuries sur les matières premières
mais ce qui est encore plus intéressant
il faut savoir qu'il y a désormais des
pénuries sur des biens manufacturés les
microprocesseurs et ça ça tout de suite
des conséquences extrêmement importante
pour la production des voitures pour la
production d automobiles
c'est ce qui va d'ailleurs faire monter
d'une certaine manière le prix des
automobiles
mais il n'ya pas que ça il y a les
matières plastiques les produits en
plastique qui sert par exemple pour
l'emballage des médicaments pour
l'emballage devax justement donc
globalement c'est tout ce qu'il y a en
amont de la production industrielle qui
est en train aujourd'hui de connaître
des hausses de prix importantes
et comme les français consomment et ça
c'est naturel
beaucoup de produits manufacturés et
bien il va y avoir nécessairement un
impact de cette hausse des prix est la
question qu'on peut se poser pourquoi de
tel désordre alors là encore il faut
revenir un petit peu au contexte général
on a des pays comme je les dis qu'ils
ont redémarré
c'est effectivement les piles à 10 et
les pétitions au tour de la chine
à côté de ça on à l'europe qui
globalement n'a pas encore redémarré la
france insiste anne et on le voit là sur
l' indice de la production industrielle
nous sommes encore au début de l'année
2000 21 nettement en dessous du niveau
que l'on avait atteint à la fin de
l'année 2019 bien mais même en europe
on a des pays où
tivité est en train de redémarrer plus
vite qu'en france et plus vite que dans
le reste de l'europe
c'est par exemple le cas de l'italie et
c'est le cas de l'espagne et dans ces
deux pays
les producteurs industriels commencent à
se plaindre justement de cette pénurie
de matières premières du fait que ben
ils sont obligés d'augmenter leurs prix
pour attirer la production vers eux
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que globalement on est dans une
situation où avec le redémarrage de
l'activité économique
alors que la production globale n'a pas
encore surmonté les effets de la crise
eh bien on va avoir des tensions
relativement importante et ces tensions
importantes vont provoquer une hausse
des prix alors jacques dans quelle
mesure c'était notre question de départ
est ce que c'est une menace pour notre
pouvoir d'achat
quelles conséquences concrètes pour les
consommateurs que nous sommes
alors oui ça va avoir des conséquences
bien sûr ça ne va pas être des
conséquences dramatiques
vous aviez parlé en introduction de la
situation des années soixante dix
on ne sera jamais dans cette situation
si vous voulez on va pas retrouver une
inflation à deux chiffres ce qu'on avait
connu au début même des des années 80
par contre il n'est pas du tout
impossible que l'on est en 2021
un taux d'inflation de l'ordre de 2% ce
qui aurait des conséquences parce que je
le rappelle les revenus son rôle tirent
relativement gelé et puis plus
particulièrement il y à ce problème par
exemple du prix des matières premières
et du prix des carburants
rappelons-nous le mouvement des gels et
jaune il a été provoqué par une hausse
du prix des carburants
donc il va falloir surveiller de manière
extrêmement précise
cette situation et nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans une situation où avec
la baisse de la productivité qui est le
résultat tout simplement des mesures
sanitaires qui sont prises dans nombre
d'entreprises
eh bien on va avoir je dirais des goules
et des trembles
man au niveau des approvisionnements et
c'est goulets d'étranglement touré
pendant cette année provoqué une hausse
des prix en particulier sur les produits
manufacturés et bien merci jacques pour
cet éclairage qui donne comme toujours à
réfléchir merci à vous et à la semaine
prochaine